Hey youtubers it's Charlie. Last night during
my Purple Wedding video I asked you all to
submit your big questions about the episode
and season 4 whatnot so I picked 10 of them
to answer in this video with one bonus question.
We also have to crown a new winner in my weekly
giveaway.
Congratulations to Los Knoggos, you win a
$20 amazon giftcard. You can either use it
to buy something cool or help repay the Crown's
debt to the Iron Bank. Which right now is
about $3 Million gold coins.
Round three begins when I post my episode
3 video next week. All you have to do to participate
is subscribe and leave a comment on those
videos. Now let's speechify some Purple
Wedding. Careful for spoilers from the episode
if you're not caught up. Here we go,
Question 1 - SantaClawz asks who was the voice
Bran Heard in his head?
He was hearing the voice of the three eyed
raven, also known as the green seer. You can
think of greenseer's as like extra powerful
wargs with power over all of nature. It works
a little differently from warging, but once
Bran finds him I think the show will explain
it in greater detail.
We actually know a lot about the greenseer
himself, he used to be called the Bloodraven
and when he was alive his real name was Brynden
Rivers. He was the son of Aegon Targaryen
the Fourth and a Blackwood. The Blackwoods
are from the Riverlands, so that's why his
bastard name is Rivers and not Blackfyre.
I'll be doing a special bonus video just
for him. Since it looks like we won't see
Bran again until episode 4, I'm going to
wait till before that episode to post it.
I know a lot of you guys have been asking
for a Bloodraven video.
Question 2 - Zalod asks Will we see Euron
Greyjoy this season?
The strange thing about the Ironborn this
season is that they might just end up showing
Theon's sister and her force of men. Since
they're near Moat Cailin and that's where
Ramsay is headed, with Theon. Euron doesn't
really appear until Book 4 and right now we're
still in book 3. Even Daenerys stuff right
now is Book 3.
I really hope they don't cut the character
out completely, because he's one of the
more interesting new book characters. Interestingly
though, Euron is not a POV character, but
his brother Victarion is.
Question 3 - Blake Targaryen asks Do you think
Daenerys Dragons will ever reproduce?
I talked a little about this during my History
of Dragons bonus video but Dragons can switch
genders, so Drogon could become a male and
Viserion and Rhaegal could become female.
George RR Martin hasn't officially revealed
anything about the dragons laying new eggs,
but I definitely think it's going to happen.
I'll be sure to add a link to that Dragon
Video I did in the description below.
Question 4 - Jeffrey Baynocky asks What did
Joffrey do that makes everyone hate him so
much? (top 10 joffrey moments)
I know you're just trying to play devil's
advocate, but I'm going to fire off some
of his more notable crimes against humanity.
Had Sansa's Direwolf Lady killed, beheaded
Ned Stark after he promised not to, forced
Sansa to look at his head on a pike, ordered
Sansa to be stripped and beaten in the throne
room, killed Ros with a crossbow, turned Ser
Dontos into his court jester and ordered dwarves
to re-enact the war of the five kings.
That Ser Dontos thing seems to be coming back
around on him and Sophie Turner ended up adopting
Lady in real life. So there is a happy ending.
Question 5 - Dark Architect asks I think Penny
may have been the one under the Wolf's Head?
After re-watching the episode, I think this
person's costume looks like Penny. Like
they made this prop to look like her. In the
books, Penny rode a pig during the dwarf jousting
event.
If you want to read the whole scene in the
books. It's Book 3 chapter 60.
Question 6 - Jack O'Connor asks Do you think
we'll see any White Walkers in the next
two episodes?
There are more scenes of the wildlings and
the Night's Watch in episode 3, but if we're
just talking about the next two episodes,
I think we'll see this one white walker
from the trailer. All of the trailer footage
is typically taken from the first couple of
episodes. And we've seen almost everything
except Daenerys siege of Mereen, Tyrion's
trial and Sansa in the Eyrie.
I saw a lot of you guys thought that white
walker in the trailer could be coldhands.
The footage isn't great and it's not a
super close up, so it's hard to tell. Cold
Hands looks more like a wight than he looks
like a white walker. But the show could just
be portraying him differently.
Question 7 - lizbet says What about when The
Red Viper "kindly" reminds Cersei that Myrcella
is still living in Dorne.
I didn't have a lot of room in my review
video so I had to leave this part out, but
yes, it was really cool. It sounded like Oberyn
was suggesting that Myrcella was safe from
all the awfuleness by being in Dorne. But
at the same time, it could have also been
a threat, as in Myrcella was in Dorne and
was at their mercy and could be subjected
to all those things if the Martells wanted.
Prince Doran is actually one of the more level
headed Martells, so I don't think they'd
ever officially hurt Myrcella. She's actually
betrothed to one of the other young Martell
princes.
The look on Tywin's face was pretty gratifying
though. It seemed like he was just mad about
all the trouble Oberyn might cause him trying
to learn more about his dead sister.
Question 8 - David Macdowell Blue asks what
do you think Cersei is going to be like now?
Cersei was on a tear in this episode, way
before Joffrey died. One of my favorite moments
was when that servant girl came up and muttered
under her breath to Maester Pycelle and Cersei
interrupts her and just says GO SEE Qyburn.
If you didn't catch it, she's just talking
about getting an abortion. Cersei had been
talking about using Qyburn for sleep aides
too, just implying that he was the shady Doctor
to go see if you wanted crazy drugs.
After this she's going to be in mourning
for a few episodes and just horrible to everyone
around her. More so than usual.
In general, things will probably just keep
getting shittier and shittier for her.
Question 9 - Lady Zelda asks Is Jack Gleeson
now going off to complete his education?
He talked about wanting to quit acting and
pursue higher education as a career path.
He and his friends do a puppet show on the
side, when Game of Thrones isn't filming.
I don't think he'll ever completely leave
the performing arts, he'll still do creative
things. But he probably won't try to star
in another television series.
David Benioff and DB Weiss said that they
wouldn't be surprised if he became a professor
eventually. So it sounds like he might just
enroll in a PhD program sometime in the near
future. You might be able to take a class
taught by Professor Joffrey someday.
Question 10 - Nicholas Peloso asks Will we
see more Littlefinger, he hasn't been around
recently?
At the end of last season Littlefinger went
to the Eyrie to woo Catelyn's sister to
marry him. So he would get her title and her
lands in the Vale. That's why we haven't
seen him recently, we'll probably see him
in either episode 3 or 4, depending on how
many King's Landing scenes there are.
and one last Bonus Question - Chely asks what
will happen to Margaery now that she's the
Queen, but Joffrey is dead?
Tywin and the small council basically wash
their hands of the marriage, since it was
never consummated. That just means there's
grounds for annulment. Side note, you probably
couldn't divorce a corpse. But either way,
she won't get to be Queen. She'll just
go back and live with her family. That's
what that preview scene of her with Olenna
was in the episode 3 clip.
She was talking about almost becoming Queen
and Olenna is telling her things are better
with Joffrey dead.
So thank you so much for submitting questions
guys, these videos are always a lot of fun
to do. My next bonus video will probably be
for the WIldling Night's Watch War that's
brewing. Since we have so many scenes at that
location next week.
Right now click here for my review of the
episode and click here for my bonus Purple
Wedding Video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!